and the man who hits the hill and ending
number one for the reds jeff hoffman in
his first start that was the finale
against the cardinals he went five
innings in a 12-1 route he was the first
reds pitcher to throw five or more
innings in his debut since tyler malley
two strikes farmer in retreat there's a
swing that comes up empty strike three
and a brilliant start for jeff hoffman
establish a fastball and you see a lot
of them early elevated
tough to get on top of that high
fastball see the swing right underneath
that ball
and there he gets into one pretty deep
center field sends ellen retreat and
right near the wall makes the catch it
is a somewhat cool evening near the
banks of the ohio that ball not much
carry one two three goes cleveland logan
allen we'll take a look at him making
his third start and his very first
against cincinnati in his career coming
off a win against detroit where he went
to five innings like he has in both
starts
took the sting out of his bat popped him
straight up and jimenez was able to get
out pour out number one now the 2-2
ripped into the glove of jose ramirez
two down
roy hit it on the nose but right into
the tracks of jose at third base you can
see the line driving boy that
had a little something on it
ran it in there again
and jose ramirez takes care of that the
reds go one two three and a strong start
for logan allen ahmed rosario just won
for his last 16.
there's another one he caught up to that
one drilled it to deep left field and
gone a home run
he knew it as soon as he hit it yeah you
could tell by the way he stood at home
polite second home run of the year for
rosario that location man that's middle
in but that's down the one he was
swinging through was elevated he got
this one down and then he got hurt with
it so cleveland will take an early lead
right into his uh nitro zone
joey bottom
checked on a pitch in the dirt he went
good breaking goal so vado who's the guy
that always walks more than he strengths
out chased one in the dirt first
strikeout for logan allen that is out
number one
try to hold up but he went around he
sure did
and the reds go one two three
logan allen strikes out a pair
kyle farmer to that for the first time
here tonight
all booted by jose ramirez
say
second and third tying run 90 feet away
2-2
and that's in the air left center field
base hit
former score stop sign for stevenson
tied at one on the base knock by jeff
hoffman
his third career rvr
maybe that down and in you want to stay
from that down and in and logan allen
decides to throw the fastball
to jeff hoffman and
tyler stevenson needs to be able to
score on that ball a look to first
payoff
on the ground up the middle has eyes
gets through base head
stevenson scores hoffman right through
second slides in the third a run scoring
knock for jesse winker the reds on top
two to one
took some really good sliders in the
dirt
and then gets a pitch he can handle kind
of top that ball but enough to get it
through the infield castellanos coiled
up runner from first goes hanging
breaking pitch it's ripped over short
left field base hit
hoffman scores winker takes third
never stopped at second in motion
and castellanos delivers another rbi a
three spot in the third three one reds
phil maton is on the reds with three in
two aboard nobody out and they eu genio
suarez do up
oh one is ripped into left field that's
down base hit
[Applause]
and the reds dominating cleveland of
five one way
we talked about the aggressiveness of
the hitters and you can see
penny suarez with just a great
adjustment to a breaking ball
and then a little fumble
which allows j.r house to send
castillanos to the plate
and if he does not drop that ball perez
does not drop that ball he is out
but this is all about the reds putting
pressure on the defense
using the team speed the foot speed you
see the
let's go
the tag the drop
get back to the play jesse winker doing
his job as well joey votto the chant
that erupts
and he booms one into left center field
healthy retreat gone
home run joey votto
it's been a massacre in the third a
seventh spot for cincinnati
well john we've talked about the
aggressiveness
of the reds hitter as a whole
of the lineup as a whole
and specifically
the change in joy vado and his approach
to doing damage
and you can see a ball out over the
plate and he hits it a ton
jeff hoffman in his fifth inning of work
eddie rosario bouncer nice down by vano
suarez back to first save
what a spear though by joey bottom
well you see joy bouncing off first base
and then gathering himself getting up
showing the hops off and making a nice
solid throw to second base
0-2
reaching swing double play ball gathered
by suarez shoveled india on the first
double play
jeff hoffman cruising through five one
run on six knots
well cal cuatro not helping himself here
with two walks in the inning and the
bases are loaded
with two down and the catcher tyler
stevenson is the battery
runners break the pitch
and a centerfield base hit suarez scores
india scores farmers stop sign at third
it's a two-run knock for tyler stevenson
his first career faces loaded hit and
the reds lead it 9-1
[Applause]
really good approach by these hitters
and you can see a
fastball out over the plate not trying
to do too much with it
and tyler stevenson getting that ball in
the gap and the guys are running you
mention it india at second base
the speed on farmer at first base it's
fun when it happens like this
the reds are rolling and jeff hoffman is
looking for his first start of six or
more innings since april 23rd of 2019.
oh and now he makes the stab of the
comebacker india one double play
and fielding his position as well
[Applause]
i fly pretty deep right
curling corner
makes the catch
jeff hoffman has gone six for the first
time as a red
castillanos one for three
and castellano steps this one up and
launches it to right center home run
well can you say elite hitter
he certainly has been elite this year
camp of trojan is in out of the bullpen
four and two thirds innings
base runners have been a problem five
walks eight hits he has struck out six
and jordan luplow pops the first pitch
to deep left field and she is gonna be
off the wall and gone
hopped up into the seats
van luklow
[Applause]
has gone deep his third home run of the
year
blandino went back on it and it appeared
as though he might have a play on the
ball but when he got to the wall he just
ran out of the room yeah that ball down
down and in and he just golfs it out of
here
to him
in the air to left field
landino retreating retreating
makes the catch and then his tags at
third throw goes to second
sac fly rbi
cleveland gets a second run in this
ninth it's now ten to three
everyone stands man on two down two
strikes
in the pitch swing into this
the cincinnati reds have won six
straight
at great american ball park
making 15 of 18 in the friendly confines
going back to last september